give me a sentiment check on bitcoin the
market macro et cetera like how you
feeling right now yeah i don't think
we've talked since uh bitcoin uh nuked
on on the weekend uh what was it two
weeks ago um that was fun got some
liquidations some volatile price action
after some consolidation i'm feeling
good i think a lot of a lot of people
were expecting bitcoin to go parabolic
including myself i'm on the record for
saying that um but i don't think the
structure of of i guess this bull market
or what bitcoin's gonna do in the coming
coming months and years has really
changed at all it's just you know what
bitcoin does kind of takes the path of
the next pain all right let's look
backwards before we kind of look at
where we are right now walk us through
kind of your understanding of we
absolutely busted through all-time highs
went to 69 000 nice and then we've drawn
down into the 40s uh what's driving a
lot of that is that macro shock is that
just pure liquidations market got too
frothy too much derivative stuff like
what's really driving that draw down
yeah i mean so a lot of it is that you
know derivatives or you know traders
speculators were out of position so um
you have the underlying spot demand for
bitcoin you have people like yourself
like you know
the listeners of this show
people going out and just buying bitcoin
on cash up or strike or coinbase or
whatever it is they're exchanging fiat
for dollars and then there's kind of
speculators that can use bitcoin they
can use other cryptos they can use
stable coins and they can basically on
margin or with leverage uh bet on the
price of bitcoin to go up and if you see
too many people uh kind of offsides
doing that at once um essentially like
you know when the price broke 69 000 or
briefly tapped it there a lot of the
market was levering up and so so you
kind of see even traders that are
bullish on bitcoin uh you know whales
will with a lot of capital um who are
long-term extremely bullish on the asset
will you know try to try to get those
and successfully did get those those
traders liquidated you know make them
for sellers and so that's kind of what a
lot of this price action is recently i
think some of it has to do with a little
bit of macro uncertainty oh you know the
fed is is starting to taper i included
some charts about uh you know euro
dollar futures and the dixie which we
can talk about in a minute but i think
there is some sort of you know risk-off
sentiment in markets we saw the vix
which is the volatility index for the s
p spike uh right before those that
massive weekend liquidation a couple
weeks back um hit hit i think 35 which
was the highest it had since since
january of this year so there was more
of just a risk off element you know it
wasn't just bitcoin uh but i think you
know that's that's getting priced in and
has been getting pricing for the last
week or two all right let's talk about
now we've got a bitcoin realized price
and uh currently the market cap sits at
about 892 billion which news flash is
below a trillion for those keeping track
at home uh but the realized caps only
461 billion tell us kind of what you
think this is showing us yeah so i kind
of color coordinated this chart over
time and you can kind of see realized
price it's like almost like a
non-volatile bitcoin chart right it's
it's not as as you know a much of a boom
and bust and more just kind of a steady
uptrend with these these big
reevaluations uh every you know
highlighted in green and so so the green
is is basically a bubble market and
that's when the realized price this
orange uh line is is curving up where
it's going parabolic and so realized
realize cap or realize price uh realized
cap is basically the aggregate
of every utxo or every bitcoin
technically on the network when it was
last moved so um that's kind of i would
i like to call this like almost not an
intrinsic value like maybe a subjective
value of bitcoin the network and we can
see this with full transparency and so
basically realized capital the realized
price has been
somewhat of a bear market floor um
you've seen it cross under that a few
times throughout history and that's been
generational buying opportunities but i
think realized cap realized price is
like the most pure form of kind of
quantifying the monetization process of
bitcoin and so right now we're kind of
in this consolidation phase where
realized cap is appreciating to the tune
of about 700 million since the bottom of
the market in may in june and so you
know we're still increasing but we're
not we're not seeing the tens of
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
of inflows into the market which would
you know need need the price which would
need to see the price to go parabolic
okay and then what about taking this
exact same realized market
capitalization but doing the 14-day
moving average uh you've got these
really fancy arrows that you drew on
here what was this showing us yeah it's
just the same charges zoomed in a little
bit you can kind of see what's what's uh
happening in closer view and so um i put
the 14 day moving average just to kind
of smooth out some of the volatility but
what you see is the slope of that
realized cap or that realized price
increase is kind of showing these market
phases so um the the reason that this
that realized price or realized cap
goes kind of vertical is two reasons
there's one old coins are selling but
it's really that's that's because of the
first reason which is there's so much
capital there's so much uh you know new
money flooding into this market flooding
into this asset class and so you get a
combination of those two you get a
basically a green bull market you see
this you know realize price appreciate
by maybe an order of magnitude uh or two
and so um we're not in that kind of
green phase yet where we're seeing these
massive capital inflows but i think the
catalyst is is what's to come and
potentially 2022 uh or later but um and
that's kind of the macro uncertainty in
the macro situation that we're we're
seeing play out in real time okay before
we move on to the next round i want to
go back to the zoomed out version the
first chart that we showed and again i'm
not a genius but i can read colors and
every time i see yellow it's followed by
green i never see yellow then red is
that a rule is there any like a way to
else to read into this or do you always
get green after yellow yeah i mean
that's historically that's what we've
seen with the red means essentially that
there's there's on-chain losses there's
realized losses so a coin's acquired in
2017 for 20k on chain and you can see
this with full transparency in the
bitcoin utxo set anybody can spin up a
full node download the entire history of
the network and see this happening and
that coin later moves for say three
thousand dollars in 2019 that's a that's
a realized loss there was a 17 000
uh loss on chain you can if it was one
bitcoin you know this is just an example
um and so when you see basically like
say at the top of the market in 2017 to
the bottom of the bear market the
realized cap decreased by like one or
the realized price decreased by like a
thousand dollars and so so basically the
whole time that whole 80 drawdown it was
just coins transferring hands and a lot
of top buyers were transferring those
weekends or transferring to strong
convicted hotlers and so yeah i think i
think you know the yellow is always
followed by the green because
um i i labeled it accumulation
parabola um and that's just kind of what
you see is that you know just steady
increase that's that plateaus or you
know a slight uptrend that's that's kind
of the
you know mark of a of accumulation trend
and then a following accumulation that's
usually when bitcoin goes parabolic but
you know history rhymes but you know
doesn't really let's see what happens